oh what'd you do for your b day man i
was with the right i'll take you happy
birthday probably first more than
anything yeah
he was the first one earlier what time
12 minutes
about stephen three o'clock in the
afternoon oh yeah happy birthday
yeah stephen it's three in the afternoon
my birthday's that means you forgot
yeah you're out dude my birthday's over
he not watched friday's episode i mean
we shouted that birthday out the whole
come on man
cat what'd you do for your b-day i just
went to my homie's house to riverside
man did your girl go with you
yeah kicked it hung out did the damn
thing didn't you guys
let me tell you something yeah we had
that oh bro guess they're the worst i
hate gifts
it's so awkward no you like gifts i love
gifts you do love gifts
it's just like okay yeah but your girl's
getting like a tv
i'm talking about like gifts where like
put a lot of thought into it yeah don't
think something you don't want first of
all
don't give me a card oh that's a [ __ ]
car unless it has i don't want a [ __ ]
car
who gets i don't even want an i don't
want a card with money in it
but what am
it's not 1984. don't send me cards don't
send me cards don't send me your [ __ ]
family's christmas pictures oh okay
don't send me your wedding advice i must
have a prison mentality shoot
me all alone give me a text message
shoot me a text shoot me that's what i'm
saying shoot me a text message
don't shoot me tax on holidays my
birthday stream it takes don't give me a
text holidays don't text me on
thanksgiving christmas yeah yeah bro
well okay we're all doing it oh awesome
my for my close friends family don't
text me
after a conor mcgregor fight like man
what do you think happened
i told you this is a show on monday
listen i don't want to go through this
every time
like right when i walked in mark sanchez
who i love ghosts dude tell me what
happened i go
dude just the show be on a few hours
do i really have to rehash it yeah just
give me the cliff well it was funny
because i was going to say something in
the group text but i was like you know
i'll just save it i was like he'll
probably talk about it we were all it
was a it was it wasn't even it was uh
the ryan garcia pacquiao thing oh that's
fake is that real fake that's right
we went over today isn't it it'd be hard
to do fake because he's
like right he's so into it yeah actually
it is that's not fair
he gets destroyed by many people okay
but but it's two different promotional
companies right can we both agree
yeah but sometimes that happens all
right all right especially if you're
manny pacquiao's work well he moves
right now he's let me make sure okay al
haymon doesn't do business with uh oscar
de la hoya like yeah this is strange
oh he's just putting the energy out he's
putting that energy so it's not real
he's the one who can get probably can
get manny pacquiao
i don't know don't think so yeah i i
think manny would take it dude
dude i think manny beats the pistol beat
the brakes off them yes
a hundred percent i don't know maybe
maybe it's a move to try and lure like
tank or
wants to fight but again i guess i say
his promotional company i remember once
boxing yeah earl smith said the same
thing with terence crawford he was like
bro you're on the wrong side of the
street
pbc is where you should be signing
that's the problem with boxing yeah like
the fighters want to fight but the
promoters yeah it's just some people
they they all have their own interests
so you don't get the fight you want to
see it's the number it's why boxing this
time yeah yeah
yeah but again that'd be a dope no it's
not okay
all right yeah i don't i don't think to
see if it actually no
i didn't know we did it on the show
today there's no there's no official
word
official oh okay that's a weird thing to
do
because that is a weird move especially
the poster i want to thank mike because
he's like thinking his team
and behind the scenes so it seems legit
he's a young kid he lies
that's a bad luck man if that's just not
real and you're making posters and she
made a poster
because because then what happens well
to take when he's trying to lure out
this one's like oh it's official
blah blah blah but if it doesn't happen
and then he fight let's say he doesn't
fight tank or kanye or pat like if he
doesn't fight a big name and then they
give you just some no name everyone's
like
it just makes you look bad it was like
dude what the [ __ ] happened yeah
what the tank happened to manny and
you're like oh no i'm fighting this
other dude but he could say
he lied behind a promotion oh look yeah
a dream turned reality
oh okay i guess it's just some flyer
he's dude he made him photoshop
number one comment duck and tank shaking
my head
but again so you put that energy out
there you just said you put the energy
out it's just a bad look yeah
because you're going for tang yeah for
manny if you're all over the place you
scattered
yeah and then to be honest you shouldn't
be fighting either those guys yeah and
then if you fight a guy you should be
fighting everyone's
disappointed yeah like it's not a good
luck yeah that that's happened
so that's happened to fighters where
it's like only in boxing never involved
ufc you post that poster it better be
real
and also if you announce a fight before
the ufc
dude dude you're in trouble you're in
trouble
somebody got i mean dude i'm talking big
no no can i let me so like has that
okay so so ryan ryan's uh uh
up and coming dude he's doing really
good right
now a guy like that like so if he fought
like manny and loses
does that like drop him down no no
man he's such a legend he's so young
yeah he he wouldn't
wouldn't have a canelo versus mayweather
thing let me ask you this oh it's like
that yeah yeah
that's exactly what it's like so let me
ask you this but maddie's even older
i know he's old and then also many knock
your ass out and he's still you just me
thurman it's so weird it's like
all right i guess you want that keith
everybody get his ass little by tennis
crawford let me ask you this
would you would you put if we're talking
about sports terms is mma
more the nfl and best and uh boxing is
more like the nba because
the nfl is the brand like no one is
above the brand
right because you have the helmets and
you have stars in basketball you have
stars in boxing
so they can release fights without their
promoter you know promotional company
i'll tell you when to release it
but you just said that yeah ufc's the
nfl okay i got you all right where's the
brand's
bigger than the fighter okay connor kind
of dabbled in that now he's lost he's
kind of fell off that mountain but yeah
yeah you're right yeah yeah nba it's
about the players but the players the
stars yeah like whether they went to
another league they went to china like
we're going to watch those games because
they're superstars because they're
superstars
boxing people boxing have enough stars
that's their problem well well
now i think there are there's only a
handful well it's like it's that
division that lightweight division
that's popping yes then you have a few
heavyweights we want to see
he's about to go there canelo's the king
yeah it's just more it's just
there's not enough they can be stacked
with superstars
yeah ufc stacked with stars but they
now they're kind of controlling them
like they don't want anybody get too big
for their matches
because of connor okay because connor
he's the one who's going to the game
he's abandoned
you know took over the game wait let's
talk about you guys watching you
oh talk about what was texting you lost
uh during the fight yeah you lost a
little bit
yeah i lost two bets this weekend i took
i told you so you
you he's you hear this hear it first oh
this breaking news so just so no one
comes at him when he doesn't
stupid i lost i took the bills off the
alumni
i got to back the bills they got
they got their [ __ ] alumni
all right so i bet i love the way he
throws around i love that
i bet with my heart on that one would i
traditionally do that probably not
yeah so you want that one so he won that
one
and then they got stomped and then i bet
the
the connor poirier bet was more it's
like an entertaining
more thing because theo is super close
with dozen points yeah yeah i'm a connor
dick rider so i was like oh i bet you're
grand
and i brought the cash but um that's
more for entertainment
i told her like i did big really shows
like tsn in toronto
with me and luke thomas like this fight
the odds vegas had three to one it
should not have been three to one
it was an even fight yeah you should win
even money
you you had said like if it's like if
you said if dustin got past
that first round then he could probably
take it yeah you said that you called
that and he took him down called that
too
hey i want to ask you a question right i
was studying heartbreaking if you're a
connor fan that fight was heartbreaking
but
because we've seen him lose but he
always he only loses by submission
he's never lost so it's always like oh
no one's gonna knock him out that's his
thing they gotta take him down
then he gets knocked down the feet like
damn i got nothing but the game
the game has my friend was telling me
the game has changed who's your friend
these are these are the conversations i
have at starbucks who's your friend
who's your friend
that's my friend like man i heard oh
yeah who's your friend hey
well he's on the share dog forums
i'm not dude i'm not having this
conversation
he walks around his key all day he
watches his fights in the game
now he was saying like it's like andrew
schultz texting man i i think
the power doesn't translate at 55 i
think he's born at 40
yeah you stop him i said you ever seen
him at 55 when he's in his prime you
ever see him fight eddie alvarez
you ever seen that car mcgregor it's the
best 155 on the planet we've ever seen
yeah but then money and fame and he went
and did his thing and then try to come
back to the game
ufc especially at lightweight you can't
leave and do other things yeah
and be happy yeah you know have money in
the bank and come back and be
competitive
you can't it's you can't be like my on
my analogy on below the bell it's like
it's like tom brady a year ago playing
one quarter
like in like beating who's a real shitty
team like uh miami dolph is about there
uh miami is pretty good but like last
year last year miami was back well
jacksonville let's just say jacksonville
so it'd be like tom brady balling out
against jacksonville
but for one quarter and then taking a
whole year off and then playing the
super bowl
and then be like i guess i'll bet on
that tom brady from that one quarter
when patrick mahomes has been involved
we've been
in it beating some of the best going
through the playoffs
we know he's he's battle tested yeah
he's ready to go yeah firing all
cylinders well that's what then you're
better on tom brady
we haven't seen he's probably rusty the
game's not game ready
you don't know what that's all actually
the game has changed because the front
leg kick
and i think that we've been oh okay your
friend tell your friends
that front leg kick has been going on
forever why did they why did they make a
big
excuse like he's not checking it and
he's like he wasn't checking it because
he hasn't been fighting
because he's been so focused on boxing
his his
connor used to be the best because we
didn't know what was coming you remember
in uh in rush hour when chris tucker
gets kicked he's like
which one do you operate that was conor
mcgregor like you didn't know what
like you didn't know what was going to
happen he was like so dynamic he was
fluid
now he's straight boxing just boxing
like not working on kicks and that's and
he got taken out by kicks
but for people like he he's been kicked
a million times it's stupid
so people just like no it's stupid he
just wasn't he he didn't
and to not to defend conor here he asked
the ufc
multiple times he even forced a
retirement he's like dude i want to
fight
fight me i don't want to just fight dust
and boy like let me fight diego sanchez
let me fight this guy
i'll fight whoever but give me ring time
and they just didn't give him fights
they're like oh here's number two
lightweight in the world and he's like
all right [ __ ] it
damn why why again so the brand the
brand is bigger than you
would don't you have to say so like bro
brandon's not bigger than connor
still not but why did he take that fight
he was like bro no other options they
thought it was a good fight
i think that if they [ __ ] up on his
side i think the ufc [ __ ] up
if you remember that fight started off
of uh a charity boxing match
because comey couldn't get a fight yeah
and so dustin has a big charity and
they're like dude let's do a
amateur boxing match where's money for
charity they both agree they come up
with a date then the ufc hijacks he goes
nope
all right we want in now if you oh no
we'll do it
uh all right all right that's why you
paid on the 500
oh okay all right damn so where does
conor go from here
i don't know you watch his post fight
and he doesn't seem like he wants to do
it yeah
yeah he's out he's just different level
he's yeah here's what's crazy he seems
happy
you know what i'm saying yeah like that
fire to be the best isn't there
he happy dude you're on a yacht yeah
gucci like you made it dude once you
shave your hands guys
yeah like to if i'm his friend like you
[ __ ] those guys save your hair you've
done everything yeah you've done
everything like what
what are we doing now you can only hurt
your legacy like why keep doing it dude
yeah get on the yacht
you have another baby coming [ __ ] it
dude focus on your whiskey yeah
like what what are we doing yeah why are
you doing this and even you like after
loss he's like man i just
it doesn't mean that much to me like it
feels different like oh you're out
yeah you're out dude yeah you reached
the pinnacle of success yeah
there's no reason to keep doing it no i
can't completely understand what the
[ __ ] you want to do but if i'm his
friend i'm like dude come on
why are we doing this why are we doing
this did you watch the fight
no i didn't get to watch it right you
didn't see it i was around i was texting
each other we're during the fight yeah i
was
with low brows we just i just saw that
oh you're watching the little brown i
wanted to see uh
uh chandler oh yeah bro come on
up and bald the [ __ ] shout out to the
boo did you watch a cat
did you guys watch it the fights yeah
i'm surprised stevie i'm sure steve you
watched it yeah yeah
it was stevie my sister and i watching
it and we were just eating cereal all
night
how about that when i get off stage at
the laugh actually
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this from a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son